my name is Thomas Dixon and in my
opinion anger is not quite as healthy
some people think it is well I think of
anger I think of myself losing it
growling at the radio shouting at the
cat feeling homicidal rage towards the
person next to me in the quiet carriage
and the Train eating their crisps
noisily it's not a healthy or happy
feeling for me
anger is a forted tantrum like howl of
protest against the world's inexplicable
refusal to cooperate with my perfectly
clear wishes and for that reason it's
not something that I think is a great
basis for moral or political decisions
today I know that individual men and
especially women are likely to be
criticized and perhaps patronized when
they express anger in their everyday
lives calm down dear they might be told
but I detect in our culture a rising
celebration of anger on all sides people
wearing it as a badge of pride
announcing that they're proud to be
angry and the others should be too I
don't buy into any of this I think
there's a real danger that boasting
about anger becomes a generalized
license for hate I'm also afraid that
people use the language of anger as a
thinly veiled threat of violence when
you hear a politician saying that if a
decision doesn't go their way
then they fear there could be civil
unrest and public anger I take it that
what they're really saying is if you
don't do what I want
then there might be riots and there
might be violence and again I'm not sure
that's a healthy way to conduct
political discourse one of my favorite
works written against angry emotions is
a book called the day era or on rage
written by the Roman philosopher and
stoic Seneca I think there may be some
things that we can still learn from it
for the Stoics passions were diseases
they weren't just harmless emotions that
we should get in touch with and express
but they were things that were seriously
bad for us another central idea that the
Stoics gave us about passions and
emotions was to think of them as choices
when I think of my own experience for
example of anger
I have to confess that there is a moment
when I agree to let it happen I choose
to lose it I allow myself to become
enraged and that if we're honest I think
we have to agree with the Stoics that
our emotions our choices even when those
feelings do feel quite hard to resist
but for those of us who do want to try
and follow in this difficult path and
restrain rather than express our anger
and outrage Seneca had some very useful
practical tips people with a bad temper
should avoid getting drunk people should
avoid the forum advocacy the courts and
all pursuits that irritate us Twitter
perhaps or for me the Today program
finally Seneca advises us always to wait
before responding to any perceived
injury he said that the greatest remedy
for anger was postponement and I think
any of us who has ever responded too
hastily and in anger to an annoying
email from a colleague will appreciate
the power of this advice thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon